hey what's going on it's bill burr it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday December 25th 2017 oh it's
Christmas boarded Oh merry Christmas to
you
merry Christmas to you and happy
birthday to Jesus
Merry Christmas and happy birthday to
you oh the lovely Nia my lovely daughter
both wearing Christmas pajamas this is
my first question what in God's name are
you doing listening to a podcast on
Christmas my class is already mad enough
at me for doing one hey gorgeous
how you doing this is how I woke up in
the morning I was laying in bed and I
felt the hi I felt these little hands
this little hand squeezing my finger so
I thought she was just sleeping just
sort of like squeezing my hand or
whatever so I took the pillow off my
giant head and I looked over and she was
sitting up when I looked at her and she
just waved at me
I loved the way she waves we were joking
my daughter waves at you from like 6
inches away she waves like she's on a
luxury liner like cruise boat and you're
you you're a hundred yards away on the
dock it's this giant wave like hey I'm
right here you got blueberry all over
your face anyways merry Christmas to
everybody you know I was gonna tease
everybody about what are you doing you
know it's funny this is a tough time of
year to be alone gee bill you really
went in deep into your brain to figure
that one out
not only alone then they got all these
damn they got all these damn songs that
just make you feel worse about yourself
you know if your life stinks and you're
sitting there going out what have I done
with my life I pushed everybody away I'm
all alone and as you're thinking that
all you hear in the background as you're
walking through the liquor store is just
it's the most wonderful time of the year
they got to update that right unless
you're divorced and you can't see your
kids cuz your wife is cogged ex-wife
sorry it's the most wonderful time of
year I do actually you know I am envious
this is when you know if you don't even
care that you're alone today you are a
true loner you're a first-ballot Hall of
Fame or what
although all the cliches you know Mount
Rushmore I mean one time I spent a
Thanksgiving alone
and this is how this is out deep and
dark my life was I thought it was
hilarious I was now I wasn't sad for any
moment during the day I thought it was
hilarious
I didn't have any turkey any any of the
fixings any of that stuff and I actually
I called up this other comic I think it
was Ryan Dalton one of my friends from
Cleveland and I believe he just came
over to my drab New York apartment and
we just sat there getting shit-faced you
know I just I was in the point in my
life I was just so excited that I wasn't
in a relationship so there was no like
because at that point I didn't even know
how to be in one so the fact that I
wasn't in one and he obviously wasn't
either we both would've had somewhere to
go I just remembered I think that's why
I was so happy because so many years I
was in a relationship that I just I
don't know I just wasn't ready to be in
one and then I was sitting there going
out god I'm meeting their family and
what am i doing I gotta get out of it
saying rather than just relaxing and
enjoying the moment so I was actually in
my comfort zone being all alone Oh what
happened bill who gives a [ __ ]
sold billy beane town is back in Boston
and you haven't seen any beans up here
by the way so funny how that nickname
just stuck I guess at some point they
used to [ __ ] make baked beans you
know kind of I used to go whaling and
you know I don't know what else I don't
know what else what else you make
buckles for hats for the pilgrims but
for summaries and making beans has stuck
here now I don't know if you if you've
never been to Boston I just I don't
spoiler alert you're not gonna find a
lot of beans here all right I went to
the Big Apple New York City
never saw really any more apples there
why do they call it this a different
reason for that isn't there
New York why do they call it that right
it is right there why do they call it
the Big Apple
all those [ __ ] chicks with the big
asses down there apple bottom seller
this my Big Apple is a nickname for New
York City it was first popularized in
the 1920s by Jay Fitzgerald what John
Jay Fitzgerald okay a sports writer for
New York when its popularity since what
the [ __ ] why is it called the Big Apple
I don't give a [ __ ] about John Jay
Fitzgerald origin of the name well
somebody's calling me I'm not answering
that okay although the history of the
Big Apple was once thought a mystery a
clear picture of the term history has
emerged due to the work of amateur
etymologist Barry popeck and Gerald
Cowan who gives a [ __ ] about them a
number of false theories I don't care
about those Oh include okay why actually
like this one a theory previously
existed including a claim that the term
derived from a woman named Eve who ran a
brothel in the city this was
subsequently exposed as a hoax I love
how they figure out that it's a hoax how
do you figure that out like where would
you start you know especially have they
been calling it that or that was the lie
for all these years how do you go back
in fact check it new evidence suggests
the earliest known usage of the Big
Apple in a book in the book the the
wayfarer in New York I have you know the
Wayfarers sounds like a fat person eats
crackers
that's wafers those are cookies wait
what is it is a literally a whole
[ __ ] page here in which and uh
William safety considered in this
coinage what where is the answer
Kansas is apt to see in New York City a
greedy City its inclined to think that
the Big Apple gets a disproportionate
share of the national SAP also that line
from the book Kansas is apt to see in
New York City in in in New York a greedy
City it inclines to think that the Big
Apple gets a disproportionate share of
the national SAP by you know hey you
know I don't feel like I'm any closer to
understanding why it's called that what
the [ __ ] does that mean so that the way
that's worded it seems like they were
already calling it the Big Apple or you
know because if you read like Tom Sawyer
and everything to like hey you know if
you if you whitewash my fence I'll give
you an apple and they're like boy oh boy
you know cuz they didn't have any
Snickers Bligh's so an apple was like a
tree it was a treat back then so maybe
that was their big dessert I get the
[ __ ] out people making pies that's all
women did back then they weren't allowed
to vote right you know they just sat
around making pies
you know bitching that they weren't out
in the fields behind a [ __ ] tema
oxygen why do you get to go out there
and smell that auction hey lady you want
to do this you're [ __ ] sitting here
kneading dough I'd rather do that to be
outside the elements but you know if
that's what you want to do by all means
all right speaking of apples you guys
friend you guys you guys fans I should
say of the the band Primus well their
drummer Tim Alexander has a cider called
her absurd ah if you like to get boozed
up go to WWE and check that stuff out I
actually had a little oh I can't
actually have a glassy pool of it he
sent me some but I can't have a
lassy pull of it until I come off the
wagon and which is probably gonna be
happen on the day of the Rose Bowl it's
my 10th Rose Bowl in a row me and Bart
Nick are gonna be there maybe we'll have
a little bit of herb site or whatever
check it out if you're into cider if you
like to get hammered and also be like
yeah but doc I'm also having apples herb
cider is this thing for you I'm gonna
check out his website here go to the
page yes that's what I want to do if
please for the love of God for the love
of God slowly opening I should have
Hotel Internet I always pay for the
extra amount oh it's got a great label
I'll tell you right now if it's as good
as that goddamn label I may be drinking
some of this stuff I love all these
musicians now can like branch out and
actually have like other businesses and
stuff before it's like they had they hit
songs and then some greedy bastard would
steal from them and now they got like
clothing label clothing lines and all of
this [ __ ] this guy's making cider you
know do you know The Smothers Brothers
have their own vineyard that what that
was like unheard of back in the day
maybe John Elway would have a couple of
car dealerships or something like that
but usually the performers when we were
done performing we were screwed you know
if we weren't out there tap dance and we
were [ __ ] what can I come up with what
should I make
bill Birds big book of [ __ ] and like all
the different ways to say it and I'll go
around the world you know find out where
I'll find out the origins of it back to
jf scott Fitzgerald you know people in
Tupelo Mississippi think that the big
[ __ ] gets more of its share of deceptive
I'm sorry
anyways I don't know what to talk about
I don't know why the [ __ ] I'm doing this
day you shouldn't even be listening to
I'd be ashamed yourself the image [ __ ]
my wife's gonna give me she was saying
he's telling the podcast today well I do
the podcast I go cuz it's [ __ ]
hilarious that I'm podcasting on
Christmas morning it's there's something
for
about that right we already had
Christmas breakfast we're gonna go to my
parents house for Christmas dinner I got
a window here snowing outside oh the
weather outside is frightful but your
smile is so delightful
that's really something that serial
killer would be singing right as you're
tied up in his cabin oh the weather
outside is frightful but you smile as so
the legislature all gag liberal
sorry I don't know what it is about
Christmas music but I always just think
creepy [ __ ] there's something about it I
think when I was growing up just
watching it you know past a certain
certain age and you start to figure out
adults a little more and you just like
you know what nobody's really that happy
this is all [ __ ] this is all part of
the lie huh full Kristopher Kringle how
about those Patriots huh how about those
Patriots how about those Buffalo Bills
that's one of the best teams I've seen
them have both games even though we kind
of kicked their ass the first time but I
mean there were they were 86 when they
came in they're looking at their ninth
one they might be nine and seven this
year you know what I say I say good for
them good for them I don't know who the
hell they're safety was at that
cornerback who jumped that route timed
it perfectly and got a very rare
interception pick-six off a Tom Brady
but you know we were gonna win any time
Tom Brady throws a pick six week that's
when he gets pissed all you did was piss
him off he's gonna come back and just
blow the game wide open huh nobody knows
that better than people down in Atlanta
Merry Christmas Atlanta Falcon fans I
love you guys so much I brought up the
biggest joke in Super Bowl history once
again I apologize okay and Happy
Hanukkah too if you're Jewish fan happy
Kwanzaa if you're an african-american
fan and I don't know what the
transgendered people celebrate these
days but whatever that thing is I'm
gonna I'm gonna make sure I know what
that is so I don't cause a big dust-up
on social media i watch the Bruins win
and I went to the Celtics and they want
against the Bulls we got a great young
team
and a buddy mine has tickets right
behind Mike Gorman and Tommy Heinsohn so
for one quarter I got to sit down there
and you know hike since like six seven
see sitting behind him he could barely
see the damn game police a transition
game when they're bringing it up the
court but I have to tell you was back in
the day I always kind of wanted to be a
sports broadcaster so actually watching
them they both had a guy on either side
like you know when they sit there and be
like he's got 16 points it's like how
the hell did they know that it's like as
they were scoring points whoever scores
their whole line of stats the player
would light up and the points is all the
way to the right I believed and I was
just kind of watching how they they were
able to do that I mean just there's so
much stuff you got to know what's going
on and then understand like the
importance of what's going on like when
you watch a game at home you know what's
going on you're into the flow of the
game and then you're talking about the
next day at work and so much of that is
because of what the announcers are
telling you this is a big play here
they've got to convert to start down and
then they don't oh that was devastating
you go to work like no it was very poor
good you don't even realize you just
you're just saying what the [ __ ] they
already said what's when you go to the
game by yourself you know there's so
much there's just so much crap going on
good lord every time there's a stoppage
of play they had this this this group of
kids little funk they always have these
kids dancing okay fine I hate it I hate
teen kids and show business that young
it's like you should be out building a
goddamn snowman going out doing this hoe
dance routine how long did you work on
that just picture some mean [ __ ]
teacher we're not leaving till we get it
right from the top five six seven eight
right they have that they got [ __ ]
Santa Claus coming out breakdance and
spin it on his head and it really kills
like feeling like you're at the game
like I was heckling the Bulls coach
guy's name was Fred something or other
you know we were sitting down low so
kept standing up and those damn coaches
they like block your view so I'm going
egg Friday
grab some fun grab some pine net
Frederick
hey Freddy you know you can coach
sitting down hey what what his hands on
your hip beads no defense fight back I
was just doing that [ __ ] and everybody
was like looking around you know my
father-in-law was getting embarrassed
I'm like like dude this is what people
used to do this is what you say this was
blood so there was also people laughing
that's what used to happen when there
was just stop it should play fans would
yell out what they thought should have
been going on you know
Haidee once you let him get to the
[ __ ] elbow again how many times you
gotta hit that shot on you and everybody
would laugh now the second that damn
things up are you running gay gay gay
gay gay gay gay
no these [ __ ] kids run out on the
court it's like I'm trying to get drunk
and yell at people that I don't know why
are you bringing kids into this but I
was stoned sober anyway so we went but
either way the game was great and just
seeing the Celtics live how young they
are and even I benches great I've keep
forgetting the name what's the name of
our sort of Center the big white guy he
looks like a yoga instructor that
moonlights as a lumberjack you know he's
got the man bun going so you know he's
spiritual he's progressive and then he's
got the giant beard so he can't tell us
this guy like a hipster is he from the
Pacific Northwest and he and his
grandfather used to get on either end of
an accent oh wow oh I didn't take a
[ __ ] tree down whatever the hell they
did out there what's-his-face Rosa had
this monster [ __ ] dunk towards the
end of the game explosive something you
never used to see on the Celtics we used
to be a bunch of slow white guys even
our black guys was slow just hanging out
with the white guys they didn't have to
try try as hard and practice and then
they sort of became like
you know almost not black anymore they
were like mixed they had a little bit
too much white in them next thing you
know they had developed an outside shot
this is all true this is why we had a
tough time keeping up with the Showtime
Lakers too many whitey sorry I'm just
making up [ __ ] I don't have any reads
this week you know I don't know I guess
when you when you piss off cherries
berries that did the dominoes just fall
no I think people just like no one's
gonna be listening Norden is anybody can
be podcasting on [ __ ] Christmas you
know what everybody thought that and
here you are listening you know else
knew it Tim Alexander from Primus so
that's my only reader this week why
don't you just sit down ignore your
family and drink a nice jug of herb
cider if you'd like to drink some go to
WWF cider calm a grbs cider calm all
right my wife's gonna kill me in a pot
there's gonna be a shorter podcast and
usual all right let's give me an
abridged version kids want to open their
gifts here alright let's get to the
reads here comedy bubble hey Billy hey
Billy Bharata toes I like that one
speaking of Bharata I went to the North
End had a lovely lovely Italian meal I
had a little burrata in the appetizer
there was unbelievable
then I went down to a cigar bar a bunch
of relatives we smoked a couple mrs.
[ __ ] [ __ ] I always go to that
cigar bar the North End and I always
forget the name of it it's in it's a
Italian name the [ __ ] is the name of its
cigars is the last thing let's see cigar
bar north and Boston what is it stands
Adele cigar e OD cigar e we're there
were having a great frigging time and
for some reason they have this Bell
there like you would ring between rounds
and this [ __ ] jerk-off Boston guy
he's got this hammer and he keeps
hitting the bell and I'm watching this
dude in this bowling shirt coming over
you
with the Boston angry face with his
eyebrows up going hey buddy knock it off
stop ringing the bell right and the kid
keeps ringing the bell my butt the [ __ ]
is with this kid and then I peeked over
and I saw you had like the earring in
his ear I'm like oh that guy oh that guy
he's gonna be that guy and the guy just
would not stop ringing the [ __ ] Bell
I appreciated the fact that the [ __ ]
the one dude was trying to get him to
stop but then the other dude there with
the man button in the [ __ ] beard kept
laughing thinking it was funny and I was
like right there there you go that's
there's the generation gap right there
the millennial kid thinks it's funny the
other dude who was also kind of young
but probably had an angry dad did not
think it was funny so I was rooting for
him but either way I had a great time
and I want to thank them they always
treat me great when I go in there cigars
wasn't where amazing that's sort of a
tradition I always end up there at least
one night if not seven alright comedy
bubble hey Billy Bharata tous huge fan
from Pakistan saw you at the Atlanta
punchline a few months ago and it was
amazing thank you very much recently
I've noticed some as established
comedians on social media [ __ ] on
open mike rescind newer comedians for
trying their luck at comedy yeah that's
not nobody funny is doing that I get
that there are a lot of comedians around
now and comedy in general is very trendy
especially with Netflix releasing a
special every week this year but is it
fair to say there is a comedy bubble now
is it even worth it for an aspiring or
up-and-coming comic to try their hand at
it wanted to get your take on this
love your standup the podcast and
episode family thanks and go love
yourself look at that for the holidays
great great great question alright
stand-up comedy is always going through
some sort of up or down as is any
business you know what I mean look at
the NBA the NBA was through the roof
popular right through the Jordan era
then it
dip now it's starting to come back and
then LeBron and all those guys it brings
it back up and down up and down NFL's on
a little dip here Tom Brady towards the
end of his career Peyton Manning's gone
Andrew Luck's hurt and Roger gets hurt
parity and all that they got to figure
it out there's always ups and downs but
that doesn't mean you shouldn't go after
your dream
I started comedy March 2nd 1992 after
the big 80s bubbles bursts and there was
a bunch of not a bunch but there was a
number of older comics when I started
out that tried to discourage me from
starting none of the funny ones they go
look at this crisis place like have fun
yeah like a two years ago there'd be a
line around the block he's lying around
look you know needs to get me all
depressed in that type of stuff any
established comedian that shits on an
open mic and tries to discourage them is
not even worth your time look how
pathetic is that what else you gonna do
you're gonna make fun of a toddler
learning how to walk did you just give
her a bath all right I need to get off
this because she's getting more annoyed
by the second that I'm on here whatever
is my Christmas to I enjoy podcasting
yeah those people are not even worth of
your time and is there a comedy bubble
right now yeah absolutely you put out
fifty to one network put out fifty-two
hour-long specials in a year you can't
do that it stops being special it
becomes like a like a like a [ __ ] log
jam and you know you need to have space
it has to breathe it's like a song you
can't have everybody doing a tap on solo
at the same time it just becomes noise
but you know this is the I think it's
gone up twice since I've been doing it
you know it dip dip dip dip dip it boom
boom boom boom boom all in the beginning
of my first eight years of my career and
then after 9/11 it went up it went up it
went up it went up and then it started
to come back down again
and
[Music]
the ability for comedians to shoot their
own specials and sell them made it go up
up up up up up up up up and I would
think that the the peak of this it's
like a housing bubble with stand-up
specials that one network has 52 of them
but the thing about Netflix is it's also
global so it's not like they're just
doing it for the United States you know
which would be insane if you just did
that for one country it's for everybody
around the world so maybe that levels it
out I mean from what I've heard from
Netflix they're gonna try to have more
of an international flavor next year
when they do it I have no idea I have no
idea but I don't that's it's beyond my
control I'm not the one who decides nor
should I be how much so many specials
get put out there or whatever but it's
not going to discourage me from trying
to write my best hour but it's
definitely making me think about how to
release and when to release my next one
yeah I hope I answered your question but
do it if you want to do stand-up but you
got to do it it's the greatest [ __ ]
job ever if you're good at it if not
it's you know now tell you it's a rough
world okay but yet don't ever listen to
any [ __ ] ask don't listen anybody in
general whatever business you're in
somebody discourages you what kind of an
[ __ ] does that hey I want to do this
you know I don't know I mean less you're
talking about trying heroin you know
other than that I think I want to start
my own business look what are we gonna
go under I just it's actually I will
tell you it's actually good that
somebody's doing that to you that you're
getting that this early in this business
because the key to success is tuning
those people out and and being around
positive people that say things that
make you feel better about what you're
going after now I'm not saying that at
some point you won't have an idea that
is you know you need to think about
again you know what I mean so somebody
okay man you might want to watch out
because a blah blah blah blah I'm not
saying that a negative response
it's not even negative constructive
criticism there's always got to be a
place for that but you can't have people
or just being negative just because
you're going out and doing something and
you'll be able to tell the difference
all right Nia I'm almost done no
response
all right rush reaction video hey there
Billy five four time
love you love Nia love your freakin
podcasts and I thought you'd love this
these guys review albums and apparently
listeners asked them to do a video on
Russia's YYZ they do a lot of rap albums
but I've reviewed metal bands like I
can't say that's Sepultura it's really
fun listening to them react to the
drumming and the guitar changes Merry
Christmas you beautiful bastard
I actually I didn't get to see this
video until you the right before I
started this and as you can see tensions
are building with my Christmas here I
watched a little bit of it I'm
definitely gonna watch the whole thing
was cool to see that they liked it I
knew that they're gonna be like what the
[ __ ] is this in the beginning as I
mentioned before that's why Y Z is the
the call letters for Toronto
International Airport in and YYZ is the
Morse code that I'd added that that
they're playing the Morse code of YYZ
it's one of their one of them and the
band was flying a plane and they heard
it and they thought it sounded cool so
they put it to music there you go that's
what that is anyways so it's funny
watching them listen to this [ __ ] going
yeah they haven't dropped into the
groove yet which basically means it's
not in four yet essentially for a lot of
people if that's all you listen to
alright original six nonsense hi Bill I
want to know your what your thoughts are
on the original six I call it the
original who gives a [ __ ] this sounds
like somebody doesn't have an original
60 no other sports hold clubs up on a
pedestal above the rest
the teams in the league it's like all
the other clubs in the NHL are less than
because they weren't from the beginning
as a Ducks fan now Jesus you're not a
Ducks fan you're a Mighty Ducks we
you're named after a Disney movie I get
it no you can't win enough cups to try
to get some sort of [ __ ] manly vibe
on your team as a Ducks fan I know you
hate them I don't hate them I don't
I went out and supported them with those
gay uniforms and gay name it was always
humiliating playing the wings or Boston
in those eggplant [ __ ] up green colors
with the cartoon duck on their Jersey
well it made sense it was named after a
kids movie I think we've earned some
respect for going through the [ __ ] you
did you did your daddy Teemu Selanne and
had all those guys that angry bastard
from was it from Vancouver you have down
there the hell's his name Ryan or some
[ __ ]
cartoon duck in the Jersey I think we've
earned some respect for going through
that [ __ ] I was like it was like wearing
a dress to a biker bar every game I
can't stand every time we play the Leafs
or Montreal they always mentioned the
original six [ __ ] anyways I wanted
to know what your take is on the
original six well I love sports history
so I like it and even if I didn't have a
team that was in the original six I
liked the expansion six I'll see if I
can still name them that's the fly is
the Penguins no boy
the California golden seals the st.
Louis Blues nice to be able to rattle
this off every team is from the
Minnesota North Stars and the Los
Angeles Kings roof by the skin of my
teeth I did that and then for those who
don't know the California golden seals
moved to Cleveland became the Cleveland
Barons and that went under and I believe
merged or something with Minnesota I
can't remember
I don't remember any ice no all that
[ __ ] I like the original six I wish more
leagues would talk about that type of
stuff you know like the NFL and that
type of stuff I just think I think it's
interesting personally I wish the NFL
actually acknowledged NFL titles the way
baseball basketball and hockey all count
they all count titles to the beginning
of their league I mean the Montreal
Canadiens they like they once Stanley
Cups against the Montreal Maroons and
the Stanley Cup was like the size of a
shot glass I mean it is the history
they probably played the final game on a
[ __ ] pond but I mean that is the
history of the league but I don't
understand what the NFL is how the Green
Bay Packers are not the Yankees of the
NFL they was talking about the
Pittsburgh Steelers because they've
they've won six Super Bowls but the
Pittsburgh Steelers were around back in
the early days of the NFL and had an
opportunity every year to win an NFL
title and they didn't and Green Bay did
and for some reason Green Bay is like
what are they green bay you got four
titles so it is four or five four for
some reason they just go they got four
they're there to behind the Steelers and
they have like eleven NFL titles plus
four Super Bowls so in my world they're
up around 14 15 whatever it is and then
you got the [ __ ] Lakers who count a
baa they want some league the baa or
something like that and they want to
title there they count that as an NBA
title I mean that's one of the biggest
[ __ ] stats in [ __ ] sports how the
hell you win an NBA title before there's
an NBA the NFL like look the NHL like
you know when the WHL went down or the
AHL they've absorbed teams as did the
NBA right but it was still the NBA right
when we they absorb like the ABA you
know those ABA teams
went into the NBA the difference with
the Lakers is the NBA didn't even exist
there was no NBA there it was like
wrestling before it got unified there
was a little [ __ ] league here a
little [ __ ] league there and another
[ __ ] league and the Lakers were in
one of those [ __ ] leagues and for
some reason they get to count that
[ __ ] league title as an NBA title
because eventually all the leagues
combine the two leagues or something
combined and it became a stronger league
and that was an NBA title
not yet [ __ ] league one you know
that's like counting like when they had
the AFL like the San Diego Chargers
claiming that they won like a [ __ ]
Super Bowl is some [ __ ] because they won
an AFL title one year but whatever
that's what it is it's very LA to pad
your [ __ ] resume so for some reason
nobody calls him on it so I LA I love
the original six I think it's cool and
it's also you know there were more teams
the RIT have been the depression hit and
then they went down to six teams that
was the deal
according to bartnik the Pittsburgh
Penguins were around or some team from
Pittsburgh and they had black and gold
because the Bruins always said the
Penguins took their colors and he goes
no we had that in the 20s at the
Penguins did he said no is a different
team it's like all right well then you
went belly-up and at which point you
forfeit the colors and then the Bruins
got him back you don't get to come back
and be like Oh forever you don't they
were already taken you bastards great
organization though all right my
daughter's boyfriend is a loser oh boy
dear Billy the Kid first I want to say
that I love the first two episodes of
efforts for family and I can't wait well
the first two seasons sorry and I can't
wait for season three thank you I don't
like my daughter's boyfriend I like how
this guy gets right to it and I want to
make her break up with him let me tell
you about my girl she was 28 years old
she has a great job she's living in an
apartment with this guy the problem is
that she pays for everything because
he's air-quote between jobs and also
sometimes she calls me to fix some stuff
for her and when I get there I find this
ass just playing video games or watching
a movie oh my god
he doesn't even put on a
Olfa when is the father of his
girlfriend shows up yeah this guy's a
bum he doesn't do [ __ ] I really don't
understand why she's still with them my
greatest fear is if she marries if she
marries that guy can you please give me
your opinion as a father oh my god do it
I'm brand new to this
you're like a grizzled vet with a 28
year old I got an 11 month old let me
give you advice can you please give me
your opinion as a father on how to deal
with this problem should I tell her to
break up with him or should I just keep
my mouth shut and I would also love to
hear what the lovely Nia has to say
about that sitch about my situation
thank you keep up the good work well
unfortunately she's a little pissed at
me right now so I only get one more
question here I think I probably
would've given him [ __ ] when I went over
there I already just been like really
you're just gonna sit there playing
video games while the father of your
girlfriend comes over to this apartment
what she's paying for everything and you
don't even have a job you're just gonna
sit there and play video games who
raised you
I probably you know now I'm not the
smartest guy and I also fly off the
handle a lot I would have said something
along those lines and then if he
mentioned it to her I just say listen I
probably shouldn't have said that I love
you I want the best for you and you know
it just as your dad it bothers me that
you're paying for everything and then I
came over to fix stuff and this guy
couldn't even stop playing video games
you know something don't say anything
because then you look like the [ __ ]
that's that was bad advice all right so
we're gonna miss strike one I would say
that to her just say listen I'm just
gonna say this and just say this I'm
just gonna say this one time I have to
get this off my chest as your dad
because I love you and I want the best
for you okay I understand that the
person you with right now is between
jobs and really try to fight the urge to
do the giant air-quote between jobs and
just say listen okay I understand that
you know people have ups and downs and
but it was just kind of a red flag to me
that I went over to your apartment where
you're paying everything where there's a
man there all right and he sees the
father of the woman that he's dating
come walking in to fix something that
he's not fixing he didn't even help me
he continued to play video games I'm
just saying I'm a little concerned about
the overall drive of the man in your
life and as men we can't give you
children all right what we do is provide
okay so he just looked like a giant 12
year old to me
don't say that last part but just say
I'm just a little concerned I do you
share those concerns and if she says no
just say fair enough maybe I caught him
on a bad day but just as your father I
felt like I had to say something if
you're okay with them then I'm okay with
them and then you then you good because
now you put it out there all right but
if you come at her and you just saying
listen you need to dump this guy this
guy's a bomb because I judge oh and
she's gonna get her back up and BRR
you know and it'll become actually more
romantic to her that she's you know it's
us against the world baby did you hear
what I said the kids would be like well
I only get to level seven that's the way
I would handle it and then after that
you just got to wash you
oh god that's difficult you got to wash
your hands of it I don't know if I could
do that I I mean I would just start at
some point if she stayed with them I
would just start openly teasing him hey
well you say they're their couch face
huh whatevs names Mike hey Mikey watch
what's your favorite couch to sit on
when you're not looking for a job
[Laughter]
you know hey Mike what's your favorite
what's your favorite movie no let me
guess Peter Pan right when you get to be
12 years old for the rest of your
[ __ ] life that's what I would just I
would roast him now at Rose soon you're
so progressive you know hey Mike what do
you want forty-one for what we want for
Christmas you want an apron well that's
right you don't even cook how about one
of those inflatable donut things that
truckers wear when they sit on their ass
all day getting hemorrhoids you want to
stand up desk to play your video games
on I would just uh yeah maybe do that I
would just start roasting him
all right bulletproof glass dear Billy
bullet-head writing to you from the
great city of Philadelphia a brief
background I am Korean oh dude I was
just watching a great movie last night
on Netflix a home of 52 stand-up
specials this year including one from me
called I think it's called big bang it
was called it was by the guy just movie
starts at his wife's just like yeah I'm
[ __ ] out of here he's a really nice
guy he never breaks the rules and he
just sort of snaps it was watched the
beginning of it really good acting shot
really well I'm gonna start what I'm
trying to [ __ ] with my my main page here
you know I'd like most [ __ ] on music and
I would like a wider variety of music of
movies rather than just the American
[ __ ] that I already know is out
there and it probably already saw what
is killing me is that Ryan Gosling movie
and the dude from [ __ ] the gladiator
I'm 20 odd foot a grunt lead singer
there what the [ __ ] his name ago threw
the phone at the person downstairs which
is one of my favorite stories ever he
shouldn't have done it but I just can't
imagine the satisfaction you're not
helping me with the phone I'm now gonna
bring the device you're not helping me
with it I'm gonna throw it at the person
that didn't help me it's all wrong but
like it's so right on so many levels
Russell Crowe
the nice guys it's one of my favorite
[ __ ] comedies of the last few years
sort of a modern-day midnight run I love
it but it's not on Netflix so I'm hoping
it's gonna get on there soon all right
dear Billy bullet-head writing to you
from the great city of Philadelphia
Philly a brief background I am Korean
and my father owns two convenience
stores both started by grandfather and
grandmother in the mid 70s God am i that
old your grandparents started businesses
in the 70s and I was alive then Wow
already watching football and collecting
cards they worked their asses off to
provide for their family that's right
old school I loved it and make sure my
dad and brothers had a good life one of
the stores is in a very bad part of town
and in the mid-80s while working my
grandfather was shot at and robbed Oh No
the bullet went over his head and missed
his head by inches this wasn't the first
time he'd been robbed at gunpoint but
the first time you've been shot at this
obviously scared the [ __ ] out of my
grandmother and eventually they
installed a bulletproof window since
installing it they've had zero robberies
and my grandmother sleeps a bit better
my grandfather's 78 looks 55 and still
works four days a week I love this guy
just this week a law passed saying that
bulletproof glass is illegal the reason
a City Councilwoman said that it made
customers feel uncomfortable and pass
legislation to make them illegal what is
going on in this country that has got to
be that what [ __ ] neighborhood does
this privileged [ __ ] live in for
starters it's insanity that they can
dictate something based on feelings and
emotions that will have physical
repercussions on the store owners not to
mention that if we are taking if we're
talking about these barriers not to
mention that if we're talking about how
these berries affect emotions they
certainly keep my family's emotions in
check worrying about other members
working in the store the woman who
passed the law is a huge [ __ ] agreed I'm
not a social justice warrior
at all but this woman's legislation is
racist yeah this sounds just like I live
in a safe white neighborhood I don't
like going in being reminded that people
who don't look like me are being shot I
mean they're just you know I just had a
latte it's also you know it's only going
to affect the pop the mom and pop Asian
and other immigrant owned stores and it
won't have any effect on the corporate
chains who don't have any family working
the counter and won't feel the financial
repercussions of a robbery none the
problem is she's black and no one has
the balls to call her racist oh I
assumed she was white so I guess I'm
racist she is though she is though my
question is I don't know how she's
racist to you as should I stand outside
City Hall City Hall I said Sileo with a
sign stating she's a racist or just a
[ __ ] know what I would do is I would try
to contact the local news people because
that's a great story and if you still
have the bullet hole and all that stuff
we get dad almost got grandfather almost
got killed
is this Oprah I mean who said this this
is crazy I see a Huxtable is that racist
for me to assume that just because she's
black that she at some point must have
lived in a tough neighborhood right is
that racist
on my end or are there not enough
Huxtable black people rapping so my idea
of what the neighborhood's a lab and who
knows I mean it's opens a giant can of
worms but at the end of the [ __ ] day
I think that you should be able I think
that that should be not the decision of
the government that should be the
decision of the person who got shot at
are you comfortable with rolling the
dice that the next one also won't hit
you in the head this is what I would do
I would not take it down I wouldn't take
it down and if they force you to take it
down I wouldn't that's I would make a
giant stink about it is what I would do
and I wouldn't don't say she's racist
don't say she's a [ __ ] don't do any of
that just what you want to do is you
want to keep the story about how the
bullet missed your grandfather by inches
and I'm much more comfortable your
grandmother is now with the bulletproof
glass and just say you and just you
killed the the you killed the other
person with kindness I respect her
opinion and blah blah blah but we work
here she does not work in these stores
um you know I'm sure she does wonderful
work he just keep doing that and and
then I would have to think that someone
in the State Department or whatever they
are is going to be looking at this story
going okay now if we take down the
bulletproof glass and god forbid
somebody in there gets shot and killed
what is the state's gonna get sued I I
would mention that just say listen I'm
not trying to cause a problem here but
like if something happens to anybody
working in my store because you know the
bulletproof glass is taken down then I
am going to hold you know whatever the
state of Pennsylvania or the city of
Philadelphia and that woman specifically
I'm gonna hold them responsible that has
got to be the dumbest thing I've ever
heard of who installs bulletproof glass
who does that
places where people get robbed at
gunpoint okay and they still have the
balls to stand there the next day and
you know so I can walk in and buy a
paper and a [ __ ] KitKat don't they
have the right to feel comfortable I
mean
yeah that's that's that's [ __ ] up I
got to tell you as a white person I'm
actually psyched that that was finally
not somebody white doing that Hey
finally it wasn't us so that's the way I
would go about that I'd kill him with
kindness and and then just sort of you
know vaguely put it out there maybe have
a lawyer down there just going like I
can't see how this the city of
Philadelphia would not be held
accountable if something like this
happens I mean you need to have some
sort of stricter gun laws we need to
solve a whole bunch of other problems
before you have the hard-working honest
citizens of this great city being put
into this level of peril because it
upsets one person in their mood that
they're reminded that there are bad
people in the world okay cause we do you
have to remember everybody is there's
two things this is the way you wish the
world is in the way it really is and you
have to act accordingly
all right and that's it Merry Christmas
Happy New Year I'll check in on you on
Thursday and I hope you guys all have a
great Christmas hunt up but I don't
Chanukah is still going how many days
are in Hanukkah I don't know I have no
ideas they're now on the ninth day of
Hanukkah my true love gave to me Kwanzaa
whenever that is I don't pretend to know
I don't pretend to be informed okay but
I hope all of you enjoy your day all
right that's it
okay if you got a gun leave it at home
just going to buy a [ __ ] candy bar
you content all right let's see you on
Thursday